Aquí tengo este número. Quisiera que pausaras
este video y que me dijeras cuántas centenas
tenemos en este número, cuántas decenas y
cuántas unidades. Pausa el video e intenta
pensarlo. Muy bien. Podemos fijarnos en cada uno
de los valores posicionales y podemos comenzar
en cualquier dirección, pero empecemos por el
lado derecho. Si comenzamos por la derecha,
vemos la posición de las unidades, y esto
quiere decir que tenemos dos unidades,
de modo que podemos escribir 2 justo aquí. Y luego
pasamos al siguiente valor posicional, nos movemos
una posición a la izquierda, a la posición de las
decenas, esto nos dice cuántas decenas tenemos,
es decir, 4 decenas, y lo escribimos aquí.
Y por último, pero no menos importante,
si vamos una posición más hacia la izquierda,
esta es la posición de las centenas, tenemos
8 centenas. Así que este número que es 842 es lo
mismo que 8 centenas más 4 decenas más 2 unidades.
Otra forma de pensar en esto es verlo como 800
más cuatro decenas, que es lo mismo que 40,
más dos unidades, que es lo mismo que 2. Estas
son formas diferentes de representar el mismo
número. Ahora, lo que acabo de hacer aquí
se conoce como Tabla de valor posicional,
y la estaremos usando muchas veces a medida que
comenzamos a construir nuestra comprensión del
valor posicional, de modo que es bueno saber
de qué están hablando las personas cuando dicen
Tabla de valor posicional. Hagamos un ejemplo
más. Digamos que tenemos el siguiente número,
este número, y hagamos también una tabla de valor
posicional, entonces ¿cuántas centenas tenemos,
cuántas decenas y cuántas unidades? Pausa
este video nuevamente y trata de resolverlo;
completa esta tabla de valor posicional. Bueno,
podemos ver que este es el número de centenas,
este es el número de decenas -porque esta
es la posición de las decenas- y este es
el número de unidades: la posición de las
unidades, la posición de las decenas y la
posición de las centenas. Si comenzamos por
la izquierda esta vez, tenemos 5 centenas,
vemos esto justo aquí -este es un ejemplo
interesante en realidad-, tenemos cero decenas,
así que pondremos un 0 justo aquí, y tenemos
siete unidades, entonces ponemos un 7 justo aquí.